you know school systems are important
but they do not supersede the rights of
parents to raise their own children you
know I did this debate in the governor's
race and we did it in this Auditorium
and there was like 100 some people 200
people and basically my opponent wheeled
in people from Broward teachers union
okay they all had the same shirt on
whatever and so what was said was okay
you guys are here but it's not about the
crowd don't interrupt don't Hoot and
Holler don't do any of that or whatever
so what do they do they scream the whole
time anytime I would talk they try to
drown drown me out and all this stuff
and whatever I mean I can handle it I
just didn't did whatever but I'm just
thinking to myself these are people that
are in our school system and that's the
way they're conducting themselves
I know we just got through this election
cycle but the school board races in 2024
I think gives us an opportunity to flip
some more of these boards throughout the
state of Florida
and and I know that there's definitely
like individual school board members
who've been very obnoxious over these
last few years with how they handled
coven
masking all these different things and
here's the thing okay they're free to do
that but they are doing that
representing constituencies who agree
with us on all those issues not agree
with them on those issues so we need to
make sure we have good candidates ready
to go and we'll continue to make
education a priority make parents rights
a priority and make sure that we're
doing the best we can to make sure we
have school systems that are focused on
education in the classical sense not
jamming down in ideological agenda down
our kids throats thank you all God bless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you thank you very much how's
everybody feeling
all right we are later in the afternoon
so we're going to need some energy
people first off Make some noise for the
governor who is here the guy is busy
he is a he is a busy man but he showed
up obviously education is one of the
important issues to the governor and you
know I say it on my show all the time
but isn't it isn't it easy to listen to
someone when they're telling the truth
right when they're just telling the
truth saying what he did why he did it
and what the results are it's so simple
and if you noticed although he had a
couple notes on the podium here he
basically was looking at you guys the
entire time 45 minutes looking straight
at you which is in stark contrast to the
president of the United States
who needs a teleprompter to tell you
what his wife's name is so
that's the difference between Florida
and what's going on in the federal
government I am I am thrilled to be here
and we're going to talk a bit about
education and we're going to talk about
the media that's really what they want
me to focus on today which I I suppose
has somehow become by specialty but
before we start uh I am very excited to
tell you guys that one year ago
yesterday I became a Floridian one year
that's right I lived in Cali communist
California I lived there any any other
expats any other California refugees oh
wow wow quite a bit quite a few of you
guys well welcome to Florida too and I
have to say since I've been here you
know people don't realize the the beauty
of the American system as it was set up
to be this idea of federalism and that
when you live in different states the
states are constantly going through an
experiment right they're constantly
tinkering and one state can say high
taxes one state can say low taxes one
state can have this policy related to
education another state can have this
and then people can figure out where to
go and I am telling you guys one year
into this Florida Freedom operation I
live in a different country and I just
want to thank all of you ogs who have
been here truly
you guys did it right you know there was
this meme of Florida man right like
Florida man he's out on the highway and
he's wrestling an alligator and he's got
a cigar and all this stuff but it's like
Florida man did it a hell of a lot
better than everybody else so yeah
so I am thrilled to be here and and be
in Florida and be with you guys and and
to talk about the media right because
the media is a big component of of what
we're all fighting right I know you guys
are at the the ground level uh fighting
for your children and your grandchildren
and your communities and all of those
things I liked what the governor did at
the end of his speech there where
basically he just had you guys yelling
out cities for Applause that was pretty
good that was pretty solid I might end
on that as well who knows a city in
Florida you okay
you get a car
in Florida we could give out cars
because we have a budget surplus here do
you know that we do we have a massive
because we're basically doing everything
right but the media would not have you
believe that right if you watch the
mainstream media whenever they talk
about Florida and I'm talking about NBC
I'm talking about CNN I'm talking about
the New York Times And The Washington
Post and the rest of them what are they
what is the idea of Florida the general
idea of Florida is somehow that we are a
very scary close-minded right-wing State
full of mean old people that is pretty
much what they will tell you about
Florida and it's the reverse it's
completely the reverse right I can tell
you in the year since I've been here
people smile here they're happy here
things are working here people have jobs
there's no homeless people I don't know
what we did with them but it well
actually I do know we ship them to
Martha's Vineyard
um and they weren't even ours like
things are working here you know what
I'm saying job then they got jobs in
Martha's Vineyard no they kicked them
off within 24 hours it was incredible
but but that's the idea of Florida if
you listen to the mainstream media that
somehow we're doing everything wrong and
and the fine gentleman that spoke here
just 45 minutes or so ago the governor
that he somehow is this mean
authoritarian and he's fighting this
culture War right and I've heard the
governor talk about this and I've
discussed it with him in events that
we've done together you know he didn't
go in when he became Governor a couple
years ago to fight some of these fights
the fights actually came to him and when
they say well he's fighting what they
mean is he's fighting back right and I
think that's the position I think that's
the position that many of you find
yourselves in because if I was to pull
you guys right now I'm pretty sure that
most of you would not have thought you
would be at a conference like this or
you'd be running to be on a school board
or even think that any of the issues
that we are constantly talking about
these days whether it's whether it's the
gender and sexuality stuff in school or
the neo-racism that's brought in through
critical race Theory or any of these
things none of us would have thought
that this was done right I'm I'm a gen
xer do we have some Gen X people in here
we got some gen xers in here we're like
the Forgotten generation right we
somehow they skipped us it was the
Boomers and now everyone focuses on the
kids but I'm 46 years old and I can tell
you I grew up in a time when we had
solved most of these issues we really
had America really did it better than
any country in the history of the war
World there are nations that are far
older than us that kept slavery way
longer there are all sorts of problems
all across the world America went
through and systematically they love
they love the term systematically and
they love systemic things but we
systemically we systemically went
through and found places where Freedom
didn't exist and equality didn't exist
and we always did the right thing and as
a gen xer
it was done I grew up in the 80s and 90s
nobody was racist nobody was sexist
nobody believed that any of this was
okay and then look what happened and
this is this is where I would say and I
say this on the show we all should look
in the mirror we sort of got fat on the
freedom right we kind of got fat on the
freedom so we just thought oh
educational always kind of work they'll
always kind of teach the kids an honest
assessment of our history and teach
things that were real and fact-based in
all of those things and they won't teach
say for example that America was founded
as its guiding principle uh was was
racism of course this is pure nonsense
but we thought it would all work and you
can't blame us for that in a certain
degree right I mean that's that's a sort
of function of success when things are
working when the system's operating as
it should when you have good people who
no longer are fighting for Freedom every
day you can get a little fat on some of
the ideas you can get a little fat on
that freedom and it's time for us to
trim it I think that's exactly why you
you guys are here so related to the to
the media specifically I think the first
thing that I can tell you without
question is the media the mainstream
Media or the corporate press whatever
phrase you want to use the fake news
whatever it might be they're not your
friends they are not your friends and
they will never be your friends right
they will never give the governor a fair
shake they will never give Florida a
fair Shake because Freedom the idea that
the individual which is the root of
Western Civilization that you and your
children and your spouses that there's
something unique about you and valuable
about you that is the hardest thing for
them to control right one person with an
idea can actually change the world but
they love this this Borg idea this idea
that we're just sort of this Collective
mess and they can figure out how to
group Us in this very weird way black
people must think this white people must
think this gay people must think this
Etc et cetera and that will all behave
accordingly you know it was interesting
because when I was listening listening
to the governor he mentioned the
gubernatorial debate and I was actually
at the debate and it was really
something to see this in person I'm sure
all of you watched it on television and
you noticed the screaming and the
jeering and all that stuff and it kind
of sounded as if Charlie Crist had more
supporters there
all 12 of them they were there it's
incredible but he makes a really
interesting point they basically when
when it was split half and half so about
200 people 100 on each side and and
there's a reason I'm telling you this
related to the media uh the the DeSantis
crew it was all individual people and
everyone was kind of dressed nice the
way you guys are dressed and it was an
interesting set of people that were
either supporters of the campaign or
whatever it might be and then the other
side they bust in all of these people
and they had their Union shirts and they
wouldn't follow any of the rules and
they're screaming and all of these
things didn't listen to any of the rules
but for those of you that you were
watching it on TV and I saw this all
over Twitter after boy it sounds like
Charlie Crist really won that debate
because they're screaming the most and
then the media runs with that now it had
nothing to do with what reality was it
had nothing to do obviously with the
results of the election were or what the
the State of Florida felt about the
governor or or the other ones I just
didn't even mention his name it's not
even worth talking about him anymore but
everything will be framed against you
guys and you really need to understand
that when you go in there and you say
what to whether it's a school board
meeting
you talk to the superintendent you talk
to whoever it might be they are going to
try to frame you as racist and bigoted
and all of these things and you must
simply stand your ground you are not you
are not
everyone knows it everyone knows it
we've put these things to bed that is
not to say that there is no hatred of
course there is some hatred out there
but I just have no doubt it's not the
people that are in this room you are
fighting to just bring things back to
the way that they were if you would have
said to anyone I mean imagine saying to
anyone 15 20 years ago that in many of
the schools in the United States they
will actually enshrine the idea that a
teacher a third grade teacher regardless
of male or female should be able to talk
to a third grade student regardless of
male or female about sex or gender
identity privately hide that from the
parent hide that from other people at
the school
potentially and that they were doing
this we know they were doing this call
that child another name of the other
gender imagine what we all would have
thought 15 years ago you would have said
this is a complete dystopian fiction you
would have said this is Black Mirror
this is a Philip K dick novel right it's
complete nonsense and yet it happened so
we have to acknowledge that it happened
and the beauty is well there's a reason
you guys are here right now you're here
because they finally pushed too far
right they just pushed too far look what
happened in Virginia which caused Glenn
yankin to win look what yeah look what
happened right here in Florida being 20
points 20 points
I'll tell you something funny I did an
event actually right here in Orlando it
was the last stop on my book tour uh
with the governor was my guest just two
miles or so from here uh on June 1st and
we're sitting in the green room just the
two of us and we had a few minutes and
honestly he mostly wanted to talk about
baseball I was like I'm sitting with the
governor what are we going to talk about
he's going to talk about baseball uh but
finally right before we went on stage I
said Governor you know maybe I'm crazy
I'm a new Floridian I don't know what's
going on but I I honestly think you're
going to win by 15 points and he laughed
in my face he laughed him out he said
seven points seven points and he won by
20. so he owes me a beer or something
but the media is not going to take too
kindly to you guys that that is simple
you know and it's interesting because
there's so many things when you talk
about the media you know this isn't the
old days when it was like okay we had
NBC Nightly News and ABC and CBS and
they were all on at 6 30 and they
roughly covered the same thing and it
didn't matter who you watched right it
didn't really matter because maybe you
watched NBC because you like Tom Brokaw
or you watched uh you watch CBS or ABC
because you like Peter Jennings or
whatever it might be but they basically
covered the same thing and then as a
nation we all sort of coalesced around
the same ideas now you might say boy
they were giving us a really narrow view
of what reality was and I think you know
a lot of the things that we're finding
out now through Elon Musk and Twitter
who is in my opinion actually saving
this Republic right now you know yeah
yeah Make some noise for the richest man
in the world I mean
Elon Musk you know this guy he's
literally sending uh ships to Mars right
now right he's doing these incredible
things and he decided to get in the sort
of dirtiest fight possible so that he
could fight for free speech because
that's how dire the situation is but
back in the day we had a sort of very
narrow view of what was acceptable then
social media came and in these last 20
years man you can find pretty much
anything online right and there's a
beauty to that and there's a there's a
sort of scary element to that too and
then what are we finding in these last
it's literally in the last say two weeks
we are now finding out that the
government at some level the federal
government was doing coordination to
silence you guys right and who is one of
the biggest accounts on all of Twitter
that they were silencing I'm sure you
know of the account lives of tick tock
right you guys know about Libs and Tick
Tock yeah so Libs of tick tock I mean
this is incredible because this goes
right to the part of I think why so many
of you are involved now in your kids
education or your grandkids education
whatever it might be Libs of tick tock
all she did was repost
in essence what teachers were saying
about what they were doing with their
students mostly related to this gender
stuff how they actually were putting
these messages in to the kids minds and
confusing them with the pronouns and
they them and he she and all of these
things and all lives of tick tock did
was reposted right she often didn't even
add commentary to it and between the
government and Twitter they started
silencing her they started censoring her
and now we have actual evidence of it so
the point of all this is that if good
people fight and it is not that fun to
fight sometimes and I I heard the uh the
ladies before me you know you know
sometimes being a happy warrior is
important and not attacking the person
and look they are going to say bad
things about you that is how it is
you're not going to believe this they
say bad things about me sometimes they
can be bad people the media they're not
great but but don't expect them to be
great right and I think that's also
consistent with probably what most of
your values are right that Society
should flourish from the bottom up that
it shouldn't be this top down this giant
Betsy DeVos was here it shouldn't be
this giant Department of Education that
has this one size fits all designed for
education for every child in America
regardless of where they live or what
their community's values are or what
their family's values are or anything
else but they love top down and also
what what else do they love well they
don't or what else do they not love they
don't love choice right when you talk
about charter schools and private
schools more options for children to go
to other schools learn other things put
a little more pressure on the public
education system to have to do a little
bit better what do they do they freak
out right they somehow try to make you
think that it's racist sexist and all of
those things so these are the ideas that
we just have to get past and if you can
get past these ideas and realize that
the mainstream media is never going to
come around and be ready to fight them
too I know it might sound a little silly
you guys are like well wait a minute I'm
just running for my local school board
you know in some little town in Florida
how does why is the media going to go
after me but they might and actually
they probably will they probably will as
Florida becomes the the Pinnacle of
freedom in the United States I mean do
you guys really realize that I can truly
tell you that as a as a new Floridian
that we live in the freest place in the
world do you understand that
we really do guys the United States has
all sorts of problems right now but we
are the freest country in the world and
we live in without question the freest
state in the world so when you guys get
involved when you guys get involved you
are defending that freedom you know
there's a limited amount that a governor
can do sure we have the best governor in
the country there's no doubt right we
all know it we get it okay great but
it's not just him he's making the right
decisions by standing up for what he
believes in which which from my humble
opinion happened to be the right things
and he's picking the right fights and
he's fighting the media in the proper
way he did not choose to fight Disney
Disney chose to fight him right he
really that that was it that was it and
by the way look what happened look what
happened first off they passed this
parent parents and education Bill and
they're the word gay as you guys know is
not even in the bill okay it had nothing
to do with sexuality it really didn't it
again was what I referred to earlier you
just don't want
State Educators talking to Children
about things that they obviously
shouldn't talk about and if you want
evidence of that everyone for just one
moment picture your third grade teacher
now think about talking about sex with
her does that seem right Mrs kochenauer
shoe I thought she was 160 years old
that I was going to talk about sex with
this woman she probably was 50 now that
I think back but like right but the idea
that they think this is their right they
think they own your children so he took
the fight to them and then what happened
to Disney in this very town that we are
in right now right well first off the
CEOs stepped down a couple weeks ago you
saw that right this Bob chapit guy
stepped down which was fantastic I
called it I called it about eight months
ago I said this will not end well for
this guy because you could see he was a
hostage at his own company right he was
a hostage because he had let this
diversity and inclusion Department run
rampant there absolutely rampant and
instead of doing what Disney should do
which is focus hopefully on making good
movies and TV shows and fixing Star Wars
which I'll never forgive them for and
everything else
you got it yeah
uh instead of doing that they decided to
say no we're going to be activists and
we're going to put these messages into
our shows and our movies and all of
these things and it caused him to get
fired they've now brought back Bob Iger
and if you saw it just a week or so ago
Bob Iger gave a big talk in front of all
the Disney employees and in essence and
the proof's in the pudding so I don't
want to give them too much credit yet
but in essence he said we have to step
back from this stuff and do you know why
that is it's because the governor and
you guys fought it that really is the
truth
foreign
that really is the truth the governor
picked the fight once it came to him as
I said earlier but then the proof was in
the pudding because then he won by a
landslide so even the basically one of
the biggest corporations one of the 10
biggest corporations in the entire world
that is headquartered right here where
we're having this conference they balked
because good people gave enough juice
for the governor to say I will keep
pushing and keep pushing and keep
pushing despite what the media said
despite what every what big Tech was
trying to censor and the rest of it so
that really more than anything else is
my message that if you fight do not
worry about mainstream media the hit
pieces will keep coming New York Times
about four years ago front page of the
Sunday New York Times ran a story about
the YouTubers that were leading people
to the alt-right and they included me
Ben Shapiro yamaka wearing Ben Shapiro
big white nationalist
they included Thomas Seoul and Milton
Friedman
we're the lead and that and guess what
we're all well Milton's not here anymore
but the rest of us are doing okay the
point is you will get through it they
will say bad things about you but but I
really believe it the truth will set you
free I believe it more than anything
else and if you fight for what is Right
other people will support you his his
leadership right now I'm pointing to a
Podium that there's nobody there but you
know I'm talking about the governor
right the governor's leader ship will
will be strengthened and then and it's
funny because the two of my favorite
words probably if you looked at if we
were to do a word count of what I say on
the Reuben report words that I say on
the Reuben word every day over the year
freedom and blueprint probably are the
two ones Freedom obviously I'm saying
left and right on every show but
blueprint's a new one that I've been
saying on the show and I've really been
saying it since this last election
Florida is the blueprint for America it
really is
if this country is going to continue the
way that we all know it to be the way
that it was set up to be the way that it
should be then the blueprint of freedom
of all of the things that have been
discussed at this conference uh
this is the stuff we have to export it
really is that simple guys and it's like
you guys have a huge piece in that so
I've got about five minutes left and uh
they asked me to take a couple questions
from the crowd so don't be shy just yell
them out nothing's off limits
somebody just scream at me we're gonna
make it happen
ma'am
I'm getting corrected okay I didn't say
I was gonna be fact checked up here
she knows that I'm new those were
counties of Florida not cities in
Florida Collier Canada okay I got it
fair enough I appreciate that I also
know that I say Florida like a New
Yorker I'm working on a Florida orange
juice okay yes
oh great question so you're running for
2024 superintendent and the media is
reaching out to you already so first off
any interview you do if it's on Zoom
record on your end if it's in print I
mean make sure you have a full record of
what the exact question was you know
Governor DeSantis did something really
interesting I'm sure actually I
recognize a few of you from this from
the sunshine Summit a couple months ago
over at the Hard Rock in Hollywood and
Governor DeSantis banned mainstream
media from coming in and then they were
freaking out but yeah his his he
mentioned why he did it when he when he
gave his talk he said well wait a minute
we know what they're going to do to us
so instead I have you guys here and he
basically was like you guys all have
phones you'll you'll say what we said up
here people can record it can get it out
we don't need these people anymore it
really is that simple
you don't need them anymore you don't
need them anymore so whatever you know
there's uh there's a couple newspapers
in Florida that obviously are pretty
good and a couple that aren't but if you
get your local one that reaches out to
you and if you just know the score if
you know the score you don't have to
talk to them but if you do talk to them
you make sure you have a recording of it
and then you release it and you get it
to everybody you know it this is what
they did and eventually enough people
start coming around and I think that
that to bring this to connect this a
little bit to what I was talking about
with with Elon Musk and Twitter you know
we're at a really interesting time right
now where people are waking up they're
realizing wait a minute the media lied
about Russia collusion or the media lied
about uh you know Brett Kavanaugh as a
serial rapist or all of the things that
or the covid shot or this or that or the
other thing so what else will the media
lie about so if you can really expose
them on our on their lives you'll get a
big win but you have to be selective
when you do it I think I got a couple
minutes left what do we got what do we
got ma'am
so what do you think of that oh so
Disney is is it 50 down man so Disney's
blaming their 50 stock loss on on
increase in pricing yes well I don't
know about you guys but I I canceled
Disney plus anyone else canceled Disney
plus that's it I know this is a
self-selected group but that's an awful
lot of people right there so that really
probably has far more to do with it we
know also they had they you know they
released another movie uh last week what
was it called Strange World or something
like that uh which absolutely bombed and
it was filled with all the woke nonsense
so the point is you know capitalism also
this this connects also to to Freedom
capitalism is the great equalizer here
if you don't like these products stop
paying for them you know you cancel
Disney plus guess what yeah
you canceled Disney plus your kids will
find something else to do or give them a
rock and a stick and they'll figure it
out like that really is the truth
I don't know how I'm giving you guys
parental advice I got a four month and a
two month old at home so I can't be
given advice on that front yet ma'am
foreign
that's tough you know one of the things
I I don't love the phrase Rhino because
I think it becomes a little a little too
cult-like in nature because you know I
guarantee you guys if I went around this
room and I do this at a lot of the
events that I do if I went around this
room one of the beautiful things about
let's say we're all kind of roughly on
the right whatever that means we believe
in individual rights we're actually okay
living in a country with people that
think different things and behave
differently and maybe have different
Lifestyles than us so it's a little this
idea that the Republican has to be this
sort of perfect magnetic thing and if we
all believe that that will somehow be
the answer I don't love that because I
actually think it's a dangerous game and
it's actually sort of what the left's
doing with pretty much everything right
I mean what what are the progressives
doing with virtually everything you have
to believe what they believe the second
they believe it right and if you don't
then you're a racist and a big and
everything else however to to
specifically answer your question if you
have someone that's running and they're
a Republican or a conservative but
they're not quite there yet I actually
think our arguments are much better I
really do our arguments are much better
why school choice is important why
giving an honest assessment of history
is important why not having a national
Department of Education that's telling
you how your kids in Florida have to
live the same way it's telling kids in
San Francisco how they have to so I
think there's an honest way to fight it
it's a tricky one but I think it's a it
can be a very slippery slope once you
start we have plenty of enemies trust me
there's enough people that are enemies
out there that if someone's like kind of
ballpark where you want them to be
figure out how to bring them in ma'am
we understand you're from California so
let me explain yes ma'am
yes
yes
right
that's okay
but when they say I'm just like you
Regina and then they go someplace and
they do exact oppositions sure
so I totally get that you're basically
attacking Mitt Romney I got it okay I
got it I got it yes I got it
foreign
she wanted to say Romney the whole time
I I see it I see it
um you know what look if one if someone
you all know this look if someone's
acting One Way privately when they're
with you and telling you what they're
gonna do and they're doing the complete
opposite in their voting habits or
anything else that's a slightly
different situation than someone who may
be marginally confused about the issues
and that yeah if that's the most common
situation then you gotta fight him and
you got to vote him out right I mean
it's as simple as that that really is it
all right I think we can do about two
more yes ma'am so I want to know how
many of your friends from California
have come to visit yes how many
man so the question was how many of my
friends of Cali have come to visit how
many of them are pissed about our
freedom and how many of them were going
to move I can tell you this I I brought
two companies here I brought probably 20
people here everyone is employed and
functional and happy and we opened up
offices in Sarasota and in Miami I'm
pretty sure everybody voted Republican
um at least the ones that I'm still
talking to uh
you know what well one thing that's
really nice and it was and it really
beared out in the numbers of the
election I mean the 20-point win you
know the governor obviously he can talk
about it a lot and and uh and it's worth
talking about it's important it shows
it's not just oi1 it's important to talk
about because it shows if you do the
right thing it's not just that you will
win you will win in a record-breaking
Landslide that's really the truth uh so
I can tell you that out of uh you know
something like 500 000 I think it's
around 450 000 people in the last two
years have left California and it's
comparable in New York and these people
that have left one thing that has really
changed and I fully get it with all of
you that are the lifelong Floridians who
as I started up top that you have done
it right these people now move into your
neighborhoods and you go oh [ __ ]
California I get it
I get it and I'm not kidding when I
moved and I'm walking my dog and then
the new P you know they see the new
people and I'm walking the dog and then
they kind of look at you weird for a
little bit and they go where you're from
I go California and there's always this
kind of look like oh God here we go
again and I swear to God what I started
doing I would have it when I would walk
out with my dog I'd put my phone on with
the top picture so that I could just
pick up my phone and show a picture of
me and the governor and then and then
I'd be okay I'd be don't worry about me
I'm with this guy it's all right that's
all right but the reason I mentioned
that is the people that are moving
because you guys have done it right and
because really more than anything else
because covid caused such an obvious
Rift in in America and Rift in our
ideological views and all of those
things the people that fled their vote
in the right way there's almost no
exceptions of the other one and you know
the the one sort of Catch-22 to that is
if you look at you know say the New York
election
um it's interesting because Kathy hochel
who's absolutely terrible and you know
Governor DeSantis campaigned with
lizelden who I think is going to be
phenomenal in whatever he does he he
only lost by about five points in New
York now a whole slew of New Yorkers are
down here voting red and didn't vote
there so that that's going to just
continue the sort of Separation in the
States going their separate ways but
that's a different topic altogether all
right who wants who wants to bring us
home here
yes ma'am
well she definitely is going to have
marital problems going forward
[Applause]
Nancy that's how we're going to end this
thing I'm gonna have to take one more
question after that
um
Nancy Pelosi I mean she's it's like you
know
you gotta leave like you just you don't
have to go home but you can't stay here
we should never hear from her again she
should leave she should really be
ashamed truthfully she should be ashamed
about what happened to the Democrat
Party under her leadership all of you
know there are old school Democrats that
were blue dog Democrats that were decent
moderate people JFK Democrats again I'm
from New York so Daniel Patrick Moynihan
and Ed Koch Democrats they existed they
were here in Florida as well before
everything shifted and she should really
at the at the end she should really be
looking back and going boy in my time as
leader of this party we decimated the
moderate liberal and created much of of
what is wrong with America today all
right final question
you're here a lot of Florida influencers
are here
we have obviously a problem with the
mainstream media and media in general
how can we get our messaging out
especially Us in blue counties who need
to
talk about our our new day new a new
vision that we have that all the events
are going on how can we tap into a
better network of getting our message
out within our counties and across the
state yeah so if you didn't catch the
beginning part is how if you're in a
blue County do you get the message out I
mean I would say you know it's funny I
say this on my show all the time it's
like if you're not on Twitter you're
probably happier you probably are you're
not inundated with evil and Madness and
lunacy all day long and I wouldn't want
to tell anyone to be on there however it
is the pr wire for the world and you may
not care about Twitter but what happens
on Twitter cares about you it's where
this stuff starts and where it spreads
so I would say basically just get your
stuff out there you know the young lady
who's running for superintendent in 2024
it's like put some videos on Twitter put
them on Instagram don't put them on Tick
Tock which is which is a Chinese spy app
that I know the governor is working on
getting out of Florida
um yeah I mean the guy's just doing
everything right it really is that
simple
but get on these platforms put some
videos out say what you believe and you
know what the first one is going to get
three views the second one will get
seven but then eventually You're Gonna
Go boy that one got 300 and then next
thing you know you got one in the
thousands and then and then you're
you're good to go that really you don't
need mainstream media you do not need to
sit down with Chuck Todd or
Acosta or lemon I was trying to go
through my Rolodex of those clown people
uh ladies and gentlemen it's been an
absolute pleasure talking to you guys
and I wish you all luck and God bless
the free state to Florida huh thank you
very much appreciate it guys thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell